you see this not just on these racial
issues you see this on the virus as well
you know how much I hate to say I told
you so
I would never do that me well sometimes
maybe okay and on this case I will I did
a show a week or two ago that said race
riots cure coronavirus because the
mainstream media and the public health
experts and the politicians told us
coronavirus was SuperDuper deadly if you
ever walk outside your home you're gonna
kill grandma and then all of a sudden
there were all these leftist riots and
the public health officials the very
same one said oh no go out there yeah go
out by the tens of thousands and breathe
all over each other that's fine you're
not gonna get coronavirus that will
actually help stop the spread of
coronavirus but if a few conservatives
want to maintain their civil liberties
that is deadly you can't do that so I
said I'll go I guess the race riots
cured her own a virus turns out turns
out that might be true or in a way it's
true Minneapolis which had the biggest
uprisings is now reporting over two
weeks later few new positive cases
according to health officials so you
would think after this craziness out
there
two weeks later passed the incubation
period you'd have a spike in cases right
hasn't happened more than 3,300
protestors have shown up to be tested
for coronavirus 40% of them so about
1300 have gotten their results back
already
1.4 percent tested positive that is
lower significantly lower then the
positive rate statewide the the
positivity rates statewide is three
point seven percent and among the
rioters peaceful rioters protesters it's
1.4 percent that's also lower than the
current seven-day average rate of
positive tests which similarly stands at
3.7 percent and this trend isn't just in
Minneapolis it holds up in Chicago
Illinois Philly Pennsylvania Boston
throughout Massachusetts they've they've
also seen very few cases new cases of
kovat 19 cropping up so when they tell
you and this is going to be inevitable
that there's going to be a second wave
you can't go outside
does one hold a protest or something the
RNC is going to happen they're gonna say
no you've got to stay indoors forget
about our encouragement of those riots
you have to stay indoors because if
coronavirus just point all that great
science and show that the science at
least the latest science doesn't back
them up
[Music]
you
[Music]